long before credit cards were a thing
there was something called a diners club
card started in 1949 by a guy named
frank x mcnamara
the diners club was the first real
payment card company in the world and it
let you eat at restaurants on credit and
then you could pay off your bill at the
end of each month but it wasn't a true
credit card it was what's called a
charge card
and it was the first of its kind to
survive and thrive
so i would say those are called charge
cards
there's been a few fintechs that are
doing that now american express
traditionally has done that with the
platinum the gold uh but yeah with
credit cards you're paying
you can pay off the minimum and then you
can accrue a lot of debt and pay a crap
ton of interest and that doesn't make
any sense but yeah charge cards the
expectation is that you pay it off in
full this is sebby from the youtube
channel assembi he teaches people how to
profit from using credit cards instead
of getting enslaved by them so sebastian
from ask sebi i talk about credit cards
and how normal people can use it to do
aspirational trips in its first year 10
000 people signed up for the diners club
card by 1959 the club had over 1 million
members it went viral
see when frank mcnamara started the
diners club card he has stumbled upon
something insidiously genius charge
cards and later credit cards tapped into
the very essence of human nature and
greed by paying with a credit card you
disconnected yourself from the pleasure
of buying to the pain of pain it makes
you emotionally feel like you're getting
something for free when logically you
know that isn't the case
see one of the most efficient ways to
make money is to get people in debts to
make them your debt slaves
there is a reason why some of the
biggest dynasties throughout history
come in the form of bankers that's
because all you have to do is hand
someone money at an interest rate and
that's literally it there's no
fulfillment process you don't have to
manufacture and ship them a product all
you have to do is sit back and your debt
slaves will work for you to pay off the
loan
ideally you would either want them to
take out an incredibly large loan like a
mortgage for a house so they're trapped
in that loan for half or all of their
life or you would want them to have an
insanely high interest rate so that even
if they only have a tiny bit of debts
they would still be caught in a vicious
cycle for life which would obviously
trap poor people the easiest and credit
cards became the perfect vehicle for
doing so it allowed you to apply the
same psychology that traps people into
giant loans like for a house but with
everyday purchases i mean look at it
it's just a piece of plastic it's so
innocent and pretty it's just one
purchase that i can't afford right now
i'll pay it off until they don't
and before they know it they've racked
up so much credit card debt that they
can barely afford to pay off just the
interest every month
and that's exactly how things played out
today the average american adult has
three credit cards with the average
balance of over 5 500
while the credit card companies have
hauled in over 176 billion dollars in
income in 2020 alone
this is how credit cards became the
modern day loan sharks
what do you think i am some financial
institution oh you're right we just need
to go to the bank
this video is about the dark side of
credit cards however i'm actually a huge
fan of them i own five credit cards
myself and i have never paid a single
cent in interest to credit card
companies so if you play your cards
right you never buy what you can't
afford you always pay off your credit
card every month you can reap all the
perks they give you for free without
becoming a sucker but the only way
you're going to be able to get a credit
card in the first place is if you have a
good credit score but to have a good
credit score you need credit but to get
credit you need a good credit score do
you see the problem we have here it's a
problem that a great company called
extra solves extra is changing the game
by being the first debit card that lets
you build credits you heard that right a
debit card that lets you build your
credits and guys i really wish i had
this when i was first trying to build my
credit score here's how it works all
you've got to do is connect extra to
your existing bank account extra will
give you a spending limit based on your
balance with no credit check you get
your extra card in the mail and then you
swipe your extra card for whatever you
want to buy extra spot to you for the
purchase and then auto pays themselves
back the next business day at the end of
the month they report all your purchases
back to the credit bureaus as credit
worthy purchases building your credits
according to one user his score went up
by a hundred points thanks to extra and
just like with real credit cards you'll
earn sweet reward points on every single
purchase you make so what are you
waiting for apply for free by going to
extra.app jtn right now the link is on
the screen and in the video description
below that's extra app jaytran with the
link below thanks to extra for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
[Music]
with only one credit card the bank amero
card you can charge almost anything
almost anywhere the bank americart gives
you instant credit from boston to
honolulu from london to bangkok the bank
americart will soon be coming to
southern ohio as another service of the
citizens national bank of ironton
working off of the success of the diners
club bank of america launched the first
general purpose credit card in 1958
called the bank americart bank americart
think of it as money they send it to
thousands of people all over america and
because it didn't have a magnetic strip
or any way to keep a record of purchases
bank of america lost millions
back in the day credit card fraud was
ridiculously easy but even though they
lost money they gained a massive
customer base bank america today's way
to pay by 1966 the idea behind the
credit card was so popular bank of
america started licensing it to other
banks then a merger in the 70s created
visa and the credit competition was
officially on by the 80s most credit
cards came with a magnetic strip this
opened up the floodgates for more and
more banks to jump on the bandwagon and
offer their customers their own credit
cards people loved it they were spending
money that wasn't theirs along with
other factors household debt in the u.s
started skyrocketing
the business model worked perfectly but
there was still something missing
profit
at the time these credit cards were only
charging four to five percent interest
compared to today's average of over 16
sure banks were making modest money off
of the interest they charged but in most
cases they were legally barred from
raising rates higher they needed a way
to charge people more for using credits
they needed to turn this new genius tool
that made people think that they could
buy stuff for free into a loan sharking
tool
and by the late 80s and early 90s they
finally found it
[Music]
there may be times
[Music]
at the time most states in the u.s had a
lot of regulations that prevented credit
card companies from raising interest
rates but then one state budgets south
dakota eliminates its cap on credit
interest rates the state had been
cash-strapped for decades and charging
more interest was their hail mary their
last-ditch effort to avoid drowning in
bankruptcy and it got even better for
credit card companies just a few years
later the u.s supreme court passes the
marquette decision allowing banks to
export their interest rates to other
states this was incredibly important
because it meant that if a bank was
based in south dakota and had an
interest rate of 25 percent they could
charge that same percentage all over the
us regardless of the interest rate loss
in the other states effectively the
interest rate cap in other states became
meaningless
suddenly all the banks wanted to move to
south dakota and because they could
charge a lot more interest they started
offering credit cards to everyone
college students young adults the
unemployed everyone gets a credit card
[Applause]
but if you were one of these more risky
individuals you would just have to pay
an insanely high interest rates that
could keep you trapped for life it got
to the point where citibank was one of
the most profitable businesses in the
early 2000s then the supreme court
passes another decision called smiley it
removed the last bits of regulation on
late fees and interest and basically
gave banks free reign to rake in the
money the results things like 36
interest rates or changing clients
interest rates at a moment's notice a 36
interest rate meant that if you took two
years to pay back a 10 000 credit
balance you would actually be paying the
bank over fourteen thousand dollars and
around five hundred ninety dollars every
month
most people can't afford six hundred
dollars a month and end up being trapped
for much longer even people who never
missed the payment suddenly found that
their interest rates had almost tripled
but there was pretty much nothing they
could do about it and the credit card
companies were just getting started
[Music]
evidently some people have money to burn
why else would they pay an outrageous
fee to carry a simple credit card
when they could carry the discover card
the card that charges no annual seed yet
pays cash back on every charge which
means it puts money into your pocket
instead of burning a hole in it
it pays to discover
by the 2000s credit card usage had
doubled even in low-income households
after taking control of interest rates
their next target was getting new
customers and obviously the client based
the target were young impressionable
college students most of them wanted
extra cash and wouldn't be bothered to
read the fine prints a perfect
combination most of them were also
likely to miss payments which meant
credit card companies could slap them
with late fees and penalties a credit
card company's worst nightmare is a
customer that pays off their debt every
month because they get all the benefits
without paying the interest what they
really want are the revolvers people who
can't afford to pay back their debt so
the amount of money they owe just gets
bigger and bigger american credit card
companies were starting to look like
high-class loan sharks they would hire
teams of lawyers to write their
contracts then bury hundreds of
loopholes in the fine prints these
loopholes gave them the power to raise
interest rates even if you missed the
payment on another creditor's loan
choose public holidays or weekends for
payment due dates so there was a greater
chance your money would arrive late they
would even advertise going paperless to
save the environments when the reality
is they know most people aren't likely
to read the fine print in an email
looking for even more customers credit
card companies started offering
attractive rewards and cashback rewards
for using their cards they will offer
zero percent fees for the first six
months to a year to get you used to
missing payments and not feeling the
pain of getting charged interests until
it becomes a habit and they even lower
their minimum payment from five percent
to two percent
small one card visa makes sense today
the average american family has over
eight thousand dollars in credit card
debts and most of it is just collecting
more and more penalties for late
payments and even when families declare
bankruptcy they still get offers from
dozens of credit card companies for even
more money they can spend now all this
may sound bad but there's a way to fight
back a way to beat the credit card
companies at their own game
hi i'm donald trump to talk to you about
the remarkable convenience of the visa
check car
everyone knows the visa check card's
directly connected to the money in your
checking account
oops but if your card's lost or stolen
did you know you're not liable for
fraudulent purchases
[Music]
see i actually love credit cards i
myself have five cards right now and
every single purchase i make goes on my
credit card and i've never paid a single
cent in interest to credit card
companies ever
have you ever paid a single cent
interest
no doesn't really make sense to because
like the interest rates are crazy so why
yeah why would i ever put myself in a
situation to do that
how long have you had credit cards
um probably like eight years or so i i
yeah it's been a pretty long time while
at the same time i still get to enjoy
all the perks they offer for free so
what kind of benefits do you enjoy these
days i think the most
useful ones that i appreciate every day
now is airline lounge access so the
platinum card you get access to delta
side clubs and also centurion lounges i
think you went to the centurion lounge
in london yeah for me i think it
elevates that airport experience a lot
more
so a lot of people associate airports
with just terrible experiences sitting
around crowded
uh waiting hours on end and when you
have lounge cards you kind of i don't
know you kind of appreciate it a lot
more you're like oh i can just drink
free alcohol and have free food and have
free coffee and hang out on my laptop
for an hour or two it's not that bad
like i don't really mind doing that and
it's a lot more comfortable and a lot of
those cards the annual fee sounds very
aggressive because you see this 700
number but a lot of people don't realize
that there's a lot of credits and you
might not use every single credit but it
makes it a lot more reasonable so that
700 might really only be 200
and then if you let's say fly every
quarter that's like about 50 per like
trip that's not too bad and then if you
fly more obviously it becomes even
better and then with points with like
intro bonuses uh you can do just really
cool trips so right now i'm in vail
saving a crap ton of money because each
night here is supposed to be two
thousand dollars and if you like go
around and you hear other people talking
and the watches people are wearing you
know that people are dropping a lot of
money here and i'm like oh i'm here
using points and it's like 25 000 points
that's effectively 250 dollars
but yeah so i'm spending 250 worth of
points for something that costs 2 000 a
night that's a no-brainer to me are you
always getting new credit cards to get
more points or how's that work so
there's a lot of different roles
involved where you can only get certain
bonuses either once every two years or
once in a lifetime so a lot of the once
in a lifetime cards american express
ones are pretty much gotten every single
card so like there's no more bonuses for
me over there but with something like
chase i can now circle back and get
other chase bonuses
literally the only thing you have to do
to make sure you don't get screwed over
by credit card companies is to one don't
buy what you can't afford if you
wouldn't use your own cash on it don't
use a credit card and two pay it off
every month if you just do those two
things you will never pay a single
diamond interest or fees to credit card
companies
the average american i think has like 5k
and credit card debt or whatever so
how do you view credit cards i think
it's like a knife or like alcohol so if
you're someone who's irresponsible
i mean anyone can be very dangerous with
a knife right but if you're if
somebody's trying to be a chef or even
alcohol is a good example right if you
can drink responsibly alcohol is not
really a problem but yes there are
people out there who
where alcohol ends up hurting them and
for them i would agree that it makes
sense to avoid it entirely but also
there's a there's a lot of other credit
cards that are not
i guess they don't work the same way as
the traditional credit cards in the
sense that you have to pay it off in
full every month so there's a lot more
products out there that do stuff like
that that might be better for those
people so they can't really accrue debt
they have to pay it off every single
month anyways if you want to learn more
about how sebby hacks credit cards i'll
link to his youtube channel and
instagram below but the only way you'll
be able to take advantage of credit
cards is if you already have good
credits and if you still need to build
your credit to get your first credit
card in the first place you can check
out our sponsor extra with the link
below which is again something i wish i
had when i was trying to build my credit
score
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you